a great young player he went to ohio
state so naturally i think the house
state michigan thing wears off on
him a little bit i understand that i
play ball i'm excited to go against the
best you know the media that's their job
you know to stir it up make it a big
story full game they needed something
they needed to get some so
they chose that but you know if you know
me
uh my team knows me i'm excited for
every game man and tom brady you think
i'm not gonna be excited to play against
the goat then you tripping
and that is what it is to play against
big time
i'm not you know i'm not going to
apologize for saying i want time no
i want tom brady i want every
quarterback i play again i love it
love it i think we need i think we need
some chase young jerseys i love chase
young by the way he was born in april of
1999 when tom brady was getting ready
for his senior season
at michigan he's
literally less than half tom brady's age
and he is going to be trying to make tom
brady pay for his decision oh yes he is
long into his life it's a great way like
he has about him like i said it just
it's not disrespectful or like me me me
it's a like a joy of love of football
and competition that just exudes off him
and you you can be vocal like that when
you're that way i don't find that mean
or malice or bad or anything
disrespectful i think it's really cool
actually
no it's it's patrick holmes is the same
way too there's a charm to what you say
so you can say things that if others
tried to say the exact same words people
would be turned off it's just a natural
basic charisma
that chase young has and uh
look we're not we're not trying to
excessively hype saturday night's game
because it's on nbc it helps but that
isn't a fascinating wrinkle that just
kind of popped up and i love how both
guys are having fun with it all right
we're going to draft now the wild card
round the super wild card round most
important on quarterbacks chris
you get the first pick if you get this
question right baker mayfield the number
one overall pick in the 2018 draft is
making his first career playoff start
who was the last quarterback drafted
number one overall to win
his first career
playoff
start wow okay wow this is um
is it this century can i ask that or was
it last century yes it is this century
damn who am i missing that what i would
be thinking of there
um
i have no idea
should i give him should i give him that
hint pete
don't give me a hint i i really don't
know this one i'm gonna throw
let me give you a hint let me give you
ahead he's playing this weekend he's
playing this weekend how dare you now
you really flustered me here
number one pick this weekend and he's
played at quarterback hold on none of
these guys what his first playoff game
oh wait so it's not baker mayfield this
time play the mute play the play go
ahead who is it
i wish you didn't alex smith oh my alex
[Music]
that is so bad i don't even register him
sometimes as a number one pick i it's
crazy i know i mean i i don't know holy
cow that's the worst one i've ever had
or one pick the same year that your hero
entered the nfl i think you have it
reprogrammed in your mind that aaron
rodgers he should have been the number
one pick yeah you're right it's messed
me up i mean the the 20 something teams
messed up i don't know what they were
thinking
all right first pick this one's easy
derek henry final answer
the titans will only go so far as derek
henry will carry them although ryan
tannehill is awesome
derek henry
is the sauce on the awesome and they
need him to have a big game if they're
going to beat the ravens as home
underdogs chris to baltimore yeah i i
mean i'm with you exactly right i look
at it that way he would have been my
first pick too
uh it's a hard draft just because
you know you tend to want to pick the
teams too that you feel like are the
underdog where you want to go wait they
have to have a guy that does something
extraordinary and that's where i think
i'm going to go with khalil men
i say this because the bears defensive
line and khalil mack have to have an
all-world type of performance if they
want to win the football game this
weekend against the saints really
they're going to probably have to play
out of their gourd to even keep the game
close i think maybe i'm i'm a little
worried about that aspect but i look at
cleomac all the money he's making yes it
hasn't been quite as good as as you know
we would have liked but it's still damn
good and this is a chance for him to
maybe take over in a big situation and
justify the money he's made and all
those type of things so
i'll say khalil mack as my my first pick
it was a great defensive performance
last year in the superdome that carried
the vikings over the saints so i think
you may be on to something there aaron
donald how can you not put aaron donald
near the top of this list the rams
defensive tackle with the as i mentioned
earlier extreme confidence going into
this playoff experience and he knows a
thing or two about tracking down russell
wilson after he busts through the line
f's up the play and tries to hold down
that seahawks offense so aaron donald
for me is the clear number two i'm
surprised you left aaron donald i i know
i
i really
i thought of him and honestly almost
jaylen ramsey right there too
to where you know again i guess i went
with khalil mack because i felt like he
had to have that he has to have a big
time game for them to win
you know i don't know the rams are good
enough to where those guys don't have to
be awesome big time all the time for
them to win but i trust me i was there i
was thinking that too
i don't know where the hell i'm going to
go here i'm going to go with miles
garrett i'm going with another pass
rusher for the same reason i just talked
about with khalil mack pittsburgh is
going to throw the football you know
cleveland's defense and their secondary
not great
so i just think if cleveland wants to
win the game that they're going to need
a miles garrett you know strip sack or
hit big ben the ball pops in the air for
an interception something like that to
change the flow of the game or or
something along those lines so i'll go
miles garrett as my second pick
you know i would go chase young with my
next pick but the thing about tom brady
is the pressure around the edge isn't
what gets him it's the pressure up the
middle so unless they're going to flip
chase young inside and have him blast
between the guard and the center and go
straight at tom brady repeatedly he's
not going to be a problem for tom brady
we see we've seen the tom brady still
has that ability he did it one time this
year and it looked like a madden glitch
where he just kind of shot up in the
pocket and made the throw when the
pressure comes around the side he can
deal with it when it comes up the middle
that's when it's a problem so no chase
young but i am going tj watt for a
couple of reasons first of all he's
awesome and second of all in that vacant
heinz field where you have to find a way
to create your own energy he's the guy
who gets it going for the steelers he'll
have a a big play he'll do the kick
he'll be fired up and it'll get everyone
else fired up that'll get the offense
fired up i think he's the guy who can
help turn around an early game funk if
the steelers just are a little flat
because they're not running out of the
tunnel with 60 000 people waving
terrible towels no it's
gonna be weird with that the playoff
weekend and not have that energy there
that that is something to watch for and
who can kind of you know like to your
point replicate the energy and
everything like that man i don't know
where i want to go here i really don't i
mean deforest buckner jonathan taylor
jaylen ramsey dk metcalf
holy cow
okay i'm gonna go with deforest buckner
i don't care that i picked already two
defensive lineman you just talked about
i'm gonna the colts same type of thing
you know i do think their defensive line
is going to have to be special to a
degree if they want to stay close win
the game do those things and the forest
buckner can to what you were just
talking about busting up the middle to
get prep that is the most annoying
pressure for a quarterback it affects
sight lines you can't step into throws
you know and deforest buckner is
a giant like he is truly a giant of a
person so his ability to get in the
middle of your offensive line and push
the pocket getting your vision that
could be a real factor in the football
game i'll go with him
one guy that didn't make the cut for me
but was closest to fawn diggs and he's
banged up he didn't practice yet i know
but stefan diggs is a key piece of that
puzzle for buffalo but the way josh
allen's playing right now although
stephon diggs has helped josh allen get
to the next level
he's at the next level
and i think that josh allen right now is
so good and so confident he could
overcome a diminished or unavailable
stefan diggs don't you i do too i do i
think he's playing well enough knows the
offense well enough throwing the ball
and seeing the field well enough that
you're i think they could survive
without him too it won't be easy but
they could
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports